cioccolata Guarda che d'estate la sera
fa freddo Voglio vedere si chiamano in
vacanza poi come ti diverti e le creme
solari devi mettere la 50 lo vuoi capire
o no che ti bruci e il Font lo sei
portato E ricordati anche la spazzola il
pettine la piastra guasti se usi quelli
dei tuoi amiche eh guanti igienico
atterrate alle 11 di sera Maria sarete
affamate Allora pasta al forno la
parmigiana di nonna Carmela e le fettine
panate giusto per chiudere il buco allo
stomaco e poi andate a cena no scusa Ste
viene a settimana sei mesi fila con
tutti i viaggi che ti abbiamo fatto fare
io tuo padre non mi sei ancora a fare
una valigia Innanzitutto tutti questi
maglioncini li lasci a casa Se proprio
fa freschino lì è pieno di negozi TAC e
te ne compri di nuovi Ma poi tutte
queste scarpe col tacco ma Portatene
solo uno classico nero che lo metti con
tutto e via le basi amore Dai ma ti
porti sia il phon che la piastra Ma dai
amore Ma sì un po' Smart Portati la ghd
2 Style che asciuga piastre capelli due
in uno Easy no 18 bikini Amore ma cosa
sta andando a fare uno Shooting per un
Brand di costumi ma Portatene due e poi
te ne compri di nuovi lì A proposito se
vai da ziz Fammi fare fattura Eh che
ogni tanto quello fa il